I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
most people that I knew church was just
you just had to go your parents made you
go you wake up you put some clothes on
you go and you can't wait to get back
and watch the second game of the day in
the NFL on TV but uh I started going a
young life and that's where I met Matt
Hawk who you know Matt's and Matt was
leading or young life group there for a
while and he was the first Christian
that I met where I was like man like
this dude like swears every now and then
he'd love sports she's got coaches
sports he's second on he's awesome dude
like he's just a really rad guy to be
around I kind of like you know the way
that he talks about Jesus no way that he
talks about what it means to have a
relationship with Christ like that's
pretty cool so I enjoyed my time with
young life we did some amazing outreach
stuff you know we went to Mexico during
two spring breaks and built houses in
like Florido outside Tijuana rough areas
you know we we erected the you know from
slab to walls to tar in the roof that
stuck on the outside like we put
together you know homes for these folks
who were living and you know garage door
sides you know thrown together and stuff
and that was meaningful you know that
was like really meaningful work and
there's not really a young life for
college it's it gets into more organized
you know athletes in action or whatever
it might be campus organizations and I
just didn't find any connection points
with with those things and started
questioning things and had friends who
have other beliefs and enjoyed learning
that's kind of a part of my life I've
had some good friendships along the way
that helped me you know to figure out
what exactly I wanted to believe in and
ultimately it was that rules and
regulations and binary systems don't
really resonate with me you know
enjoyed learning about other religions
and meeting the Dalai Lama yeah it's
been a fun path too
to a different type of spirituality
which which to me is more it's been more
meaningful would you decide would you
separate the two being spirituality and
religion like you were religious and now
your spiritual I think both can work for
people I do I think some people just
need structure and they need tradition
and stuff and that that works for them
and I don't have a yeah a problem with
it that doesn't it doesn't resonate with
me yeah how far back can you go and
identify like yeah I thought it was
weird when I was four like or whatever
is there an example can you identify
when the skeptic and the questioner in
you was really present I mean high
school for sure
cuz I had two grips I was going oh it's
going through to church on Sundays and
into young life on Mondays and young
life on Monday welcomed everyone you
know it's like great come as you are be
there at seven twenty nine yeah and like
be ready for some fun and it was fun and
we had a great time church on Sundays it
was like more you know make sure you
dress a certain way and don't bring that
person and this person is going to get
looked at strangely if they show up and
I think you know again it's very black
and white
binary in binary sense but I don't think
it's very welcoming where they didn't
can be a crutch can be a can be
something that people have to have to
make themselves feel better and because
it set of binary it's us and then it's
saved and unsaved it's heaven and hell
it's enlightened and heathen it's holy
and righteous and sinner and filthy and
that makes I think that makes a lot of
people feel better about themselves is
it oh you know I have you know I got
Jesus and you know I'm saved and I'm
going to heaven and there's only a
hundred forty-four thousand of us going
even though there's seven billion people
on the planet and you know I don't know
how you can believe in a god
wants to condemn most of the planet you
know to a fiery hell like what type of
loving sensitive omnipresent omnipotent
being wants to condemn most of his
beautiful creation to a fiery hell at
the end of all this
[Music]